welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters it's thanksgiving weekend a time
to count our blessings but many
americans are angry this year this
holiday breaking the bank for so many
thanks to our incompetent leader joe
biden's a horrible president he's
ineffective and completely out of touch
americans are tired of his lies and
broken promises and it's showing more
than ever he hit a record low approval
at
36 percent
polls show democrats don't want him to
run in 2024 but joe's now telling them
he's running just to try to calm him
down
they're nervous because he keeps
dropping the ball america's worst
newspaper the washington post says
democrat strategists and officials doubt
he's running in 2024. his party doesn't
even believe him anymore
his policies are hurting the economy
inflation's at a record high americans
can't afford gas it's averaging nearly
350 a gallon americans still
still stranded in afghanistan joe's
opened the border coveted cases on the
rise criminals running loose on the
streets the list's endless when it comes
to his fumbles and all at your expense
of course
biden's lost the american people but you
probably already know that if you watch
water's world
and if you're watching football this
thanksgiving weekend like most americans
f joe biden chants have been erupting
across america for months
[Applause]
[Music]
that sentiment is stronger than ever it
quickly morphed into a nationwide
phenomenon with the antibiotic let's go
brandon chant and americans are still
chanting it across the nation
[Applause]
[Music]
why is it blue
[Music]
there is even a let's go brandon song
that topped the charts four different
versions of the song went number one on
itunes
ignore all the crying they build them
back better but only the taliban pilots
on strike but to joe it's irrelevant
open the board i lose all the orders
you ask questions they start banning hey
hey let's go
let's go brandon
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else